il est le grand hacker de ces 20
dernières années dès l'âge de 18 ans il
avait défrayé la chronique pour avoir
infiltré les ordinateurs du Pentagone
embaucher à sa sortie de prison il
travaillait depuis 2003 pour la sécurité
de l'État d'Israël octobre 2008 il est à
nouveau arrêté pour avoir détourné plus
de 1 million 200000 € à une société de
crédit canadienne et tout cela sans arme
et sans violence
planquer
monter au braquage
partagez la fraîche
tout le vocabulaire des gangsters à
l'ancienne
mais tout un monde
qui pourrait disparaître
dans le cyberespace du 21e siècle
11 Kim
on spam on fiche
c'est le vocabulaire des nouveaux
braqueurs
les cybercriminels
[Musique]
Paris le 14 décembre 2008 palais de
justice
périmètre bloqué
quartier sous haute tension
le dernier des grands braqueurs français
surnommé le roi de la belle est attendu
aux assises un nombre impressionnant de
policiers et spécialement déployés
aujourd'hui jour de verdict pour Antonio
Ferrara il encourt 20 ans de réclusion
criminelle
Antonio Ferrara comparé depuis plus de 3
mois avec 12 autres personnes pour son
évasion spectaculaire de la prison de
Fresnes le 12 mars 2003 ce jour-là s'est
complice avait fait exploser la porte de
la prison et mitrailler les miradors à
l'arme de guerre une véritable opération
commando pour sa seconde évasion le CV
de Ferrara le dernier d'une grande
lignée de braqueurs à l'ancienne est
impressionnant né en 1973 en Italie il
grandit en banlieue parisienne très vite
il se distingue par un nombre
impressionnant de braquage à main armés
comme ce fameux hold-up d'une banque en
1997 un visage découvert
Antonio Ferrara est surtout un
spécialiste des attaques spectaculaires
de fourgon comme ici en mai 2000 à
Nanterre
les policiers connaissent bien sa
signature une antenne parabolique
entourée de pain de plastique qui
concentre le souffle de l'explosion à
l'intérieur des véhicules blindés sans
jamais tuer personne
au palais de justice ce 14 décembre 2008
7 sur les 18 complices de Ferrara pour
l'évasion de Fresnes arrivent libre au
moment du verdict un seul est acquitté
et Ferrara est condamné à 17 ans de
réclusion ce grand axe de la liberté
comme il aime à se décrire voit sa cam
favorite s'éloigner et ne devrait pas y
toucher avant 2039
pour qu'un homme comme Ferrara et 15
mecs qui sacrifient ou qui risquent leur
vie pour venir le chercher c'est que
c'est un brave mec
deuxièmement c'est un support
professionnel parce qu'il a appris de
certaines personnes que je connais
comment on place les pains le plastique
sur une une antenne parabolique
c'est un super pro il a de l'humour il
se bat en justice
chez une profonde admiration pour un mec
comme Ferrara quand on fait une
comparaison de Ferrari Mérine Mérine
j'étais un an à côté ça va j'aurais
préféré travailler 20 ans avec Ferrara
que un an avec Marine
et Michel Hardouin s'y connaît en
braquage un mètre 85 130 kg une
quinzaine d'années en prison une bonne
douzaine d'hommes tués et près d'une
trentaine de filles sous sa coupe
Monsieur Michel lardon a un dit portable
le porte-avion en raison du nombre
d'armes de différents calibres qu'il
portait en toute occasion il est une
figure du grand banditisme français
issue d'une famille bourgeoise il
commence à faire le Mac à Toulon à 18
ans en 1965 passeport pour le milieu il
exécute son premier contrat et abat-hen
gitan en 68 il travaille pour la latino
connexion il est l'exécuteur
au cours d'une mission sa femme est tuée
d'une balle dans la tête à Buenos Aires
tandis qu'il se fait ouvrir le ventre au
fusil de chasse par un tueur mais il
doit son surnom et sa notoriété à son
association avec le célèbre braqueur
Jacques Mesrine au milieu des années 70
plus de 80 banques braquées en un an
[Musique]
aujourd'hui ranger des voitures et
écrivains il revient sur son époque
Jacques Mesrine
flashback seventies
[Musique]
en passant on peut acheter devant une
banque vous allez belle oui va la
contrôler oui on fait voilà
et les équipes de l'époque l'écorche qui
faisaient il y avait une équipe de Corse
d'amis à moi que j'ai toujours des amis
et deux trois autres équipes de la
banlieue on braquet touche pareil pas le
temps de près il y a pas de préparation
c'est pas comme un fourgon comme un
machin comme truc il faut aller braquer
au jour le jour au passage comment va
acheter cigarettes du lait voilà
maintenant ensuite il y a eu des équipes
plus jeunes que moi moi c'est pas ma
génération qu'on préparait des fourgons
qu'on réussit à mouiller les employés de
la société de protection quand il
cherche aussi qu'on réussit à cela c'est
très beau maintenant il faut une
parabole savoir placer les explosifs ce
que ça va faire ferraractions
mais ça c'est pas ma génération
il y a de moins en moins d'argent dans
les banques et les transports de fonds
sont la cible favorite des hommes comme
Ferrara
le roi de l'évasion était la bête noire
des 7000 convoyeurs de fonds en France
salaire moyen 1500 euros brut
avec une prime de risque de 215 euros
par mois
[Musique]
entre eux ils parlent souvent avec
sinisme du salaire de la peur
depuis 1989 cette profession a connu le
triste bilan de 30 convoyeurs tués en
service
on dénombre 7 attaques en 2007
pour tenter de déjouer les braquages on
filtre un maximum d'informations un
convoyeur s'est à quelle heure il
partira mais il ne connaît jamais à
l'avance la destination les trajets sont
chronométrés les routes empruntées ne
sont jamais les mêmes et chaque véhicule
épisté au GPS
tout est bon pour contrer cette
criminalité née au milieu des années 80
[Musique]
un grand hôtel parisien
toujours bien apprêté et très classe
malgré ses 88 ans aux prunes Monsieur
François Marc Anthony est un fin
connaisseur du milieu mais du milieu à
l'ancienne le milieu actuel lui il ne le
fréquente pas car d'après ce qu'il voit
dans les films de gangster les braquages
ultra-violence et pas son truc
résistant pendant la deuxième guerre
mondiale il apprend le métier en
arnaquant des anciens collabos passé
entre les mailles du filet et il apprend
très vite spécialiste du braquage de
banque il est fiché au grand banditisme
en 1959 une quinzaine d'années de prison
plus tard l'homme au chapeau mou fait un
dernier passage à la santé en 1994 à 74
ans pour une vente de tableau plutôt
douteuse
aujourd'hui François Marc Anthony se
consacre à ses costumes bien taillés et
à l'écriture d'ouvrage largement
autobiographiques mais sans violence
comme il aimait le dire
le reste le journal
France moi de mon temps c'était de la
plaisanterie à côté de ça
déjà intelligent pour les mains couche
pas ce soir
donc ça se passait très bien mais jamais
eu de violence comme ça
[Musique]
les livraisons de banque
se faisaient à l'époque par une
camionnette la banque évidemment
vous arrivez devant la banque
le chauffeur rester au volant
descendez l'ouvrir on est le sac pour
rentrer à l'avant
alors on arrive à juste à temps quand il
descendait on faisait descendre le
chauffeur ça n'a rien vers la voiture et
tout il y avait de la rue rester sur le
trottoir
[Musique]
loin des hold-up à la papa des bras
coups toujours plus violents comme des
opérations de guerre les attaques contre
les fourgons devenant alors tour de plus
en plus difficile les gangsters se
concentrent sur les centres forts dans
la région lilloise plusieurs hommes en
cagoulé et lourdement armées ont attaqué
un centre fort à l'explosif à l'été 2008
et à Marseille le 15 janvier dernier
c'est au lance-roquette que la Brinks a
été visée
quelque part en France un centre fort
comme il en existe 150 dans l'Hexagone
baltis c'est d'ici que par l'argent pour
les 70 000 banques et 45
000 distributeurs de billets
mur blindé et indestructible
tout est ici pris en compte afin de ne
pas être la cible d'une attaque et à
l'intérieur 150 caméras officiellement
placé sous haute surveillance
électronique
il faut montrer patte blanche
empreinte digitale et pesée à l'entrée
et à la sortie pour chaque employé
[Musique]
impossible d'en porter le moindre billet
ou la moindre pièce de monnaie
pour eux qui voient défiler des millions
d'euros obligations d'avoir un casier
judiciaire vierge
[Musique]
Philippe Régnier travaille dans le
milieu des transports de fonds depuis
1973 il a tout connu nous travaillons
avec des spécialistes quand il s'agit de
faire des murs en béton avec des gens
qui savent calculer la résistance des
matériaux avec des systèmes de biométrie
pour entrer avec des systèmes de caméras
qui enregistrent jour et nuit avec tout
ce qu'il faut pour pouvoir se préparer à
toute éventualité avec un PC sécurité
qui peut les suivre à distance de
manière à pouvoir se paraît contre toute
agression éventuelle mais encore une
fois notre métier dans le risque est
inhérent à notre métier et on fait tout
pour le supprimer pour l'alléger pour le
réduire mais on sait très bien que dès
qu'il y a de l'argent quelque part il y
a un risque
direction Bruxelles la Belgique a été
l'un des premiers pays à réagir contre
les attaques de fourgon ministère de
l'Intérieur police société de transport
syndicat tous se sont réunis afin de
trouver des solutions
principales mesures tous les trajets
sont connus de la police et protégés
pour les convois les plus importants en
1995 59 attaques en moyenne plus de 10
par an depuis 2007 plus aucun convoi n'a
été attaquée sur le sol belge mais pour
le commissaire de Reth les braqueurs
changent de cible et la violence monte
d'un cran nous craignons des opérations
en style commando comme on a déjà connu
quelques-uns dans les pays
nordiques de l'Europe donc vraiment des
attentats très spectaculaires sur entre
autres des centres de distribution
d'argent
c'est aussi une des raisons pour
laquelle nous en fonction pour l'instant
les mesures de prévention autour de ces
centres de distribution d'argent parce
que se base des éléments des
informations criminelles qui ne
cueillons nous constatons clairement que
qu'il y a un intérêt
je dirais quasi permanent du milieu
criminels de commettre ce type un ordre
pour un braquage sur un centre de
distribution d'argent donc ça c'est une
première chose une deuxième chose que
nous constatons et ça se passe déjà
c'est déjà en couple pour l'instant que
ce sont plus les biens même la banque le
transport ou le fourgon qui est menacé
mais plutôt les personnes qui détiennent
les biens par exemple en prenant un
otage un membre de famille d'un
directeur d'agence et en obligeant par
après le directeur d'aller ramasser
l'argent
pour pour la criminels
le risque de kidnapping en France à
Marseille la femme et le fils du chef de
la sécurité de la Brinks ont été prises
en otage en juin 2008
un certain nombre de salariés qui chez
eux ont des systèmes d'alarme pour pas
être pour hors cas de problème pouvoir
informer sans que ça se sache de la part
des malfaiteurs qui a quelque chose qui
se passe dans normal
ça fait partie des risques donc c'est
risques là
de se faire kidnapper ou de se faire
prendre chez soi d'où le fait de n'avoir
absolument aucune possibilité d'entrée
dans le centre fort bon parce que on a
des badges qui sont invalidés
immédiatement dès qu'on est sorti parce
que moi je le connais aucun des codes
pour entrer dans l'entreprise parce que
c'est un PC sécurité qui est distant des
centres forts qui permet l'autorisation
que ce même PC sécurité est suivi par un
PC backup qui permet de au casier un
problème dans l'Inde d'aller vers
l'autre donc tout cet ensemble bon fait
partie de la sécurité qu'on doit avoir
alors bien évidemment il peut y avoir un
maillon faible dans la chaîne bon
le maillon faible c'est le dabiste il
approvisionne les distributeurs
automatiques de billets non armés il est
une proie facile
voiture bélier porte enfoncées
distributeurs arrachés plus de 60
attaques en 2008 plus d'une par semaine
leur nombre à doubler en 4 ans moyenne
débutant 38000 euros
la fonction du labiste chargez les
billets dans le distributeur après que
des convoyeurs et déposé les sacs
d'argent c'est le seul moment où la
chaîne de sécurité est rompue c'est le
moment préféré des braqueurs
payez 1300 euros par mois avec une prime
de risque de 110 euros les dabistes ont
en plus des obligations sécurité oblige
on dit à son entourage ou ses amis qu'on
travaille chez les transporteurs de fond
par exemple ou alors il est 8 au maximum
ce genre de d'information pour quelle
raison mise en danger et qu'est-ce qu'on
dit travail dans le transport
[Musique]
en Belgique les transporteurs de fonds
ont trouvé une parade pour protéger les
Dabis
depuis deux ans donc depuis 2006 donc on
a introduit pour les transports de fonds
la valise intelligente donc chaque
transport de fond qui est accompagné par
une société de gardénage doit faire doit
faire usage de de la valise intelligente
en 2006 nous avons encore constaté
plusieurs quelques
attentes
disons que il y avait presque plus de
butin et on a constaté en fait que le
milieu criminel même voudrait tester le
matériel de la valise intelligente
c'était le seul but en fait de commettre
ce type de délit en 2006 c'était pour
s'emparer d'une valise et pour tester si
le matériel était fiable ou non
direction obertour technology la société
qui fabrique les premières valises
intelligentes en France
une technologie agréée par le ministère
de l'Intérieur ces nouvelles valises
seront insérées directement dans les
distributeurs la chaîne de sécurité ne
sera plus jamais coupée
et en plus elle protégeront leur butin
le conteneur instantanément à meuler la
totalité des vignettes recto verso sur
les quatre côtés pour une surface à peu
près 20% en immédiat instantané mais
pouvant aller au bout de quelques
minutes jusqu'à 100% de la surface des
billets par phénomène de capillarité de
l'encre
sur les billets
[Musique]
reconnaissable
identifiable traçable 7 ans fait comme
un ADN
aujourd'hui braquer une banque ou
attaquer des convois et de plus en plus
difficile et rapporte de moins en moins
[Musique]
la fin d'une époque autant j'ai une
grande admiration voir mes conférences
je connais pas j'ai beaucoup déçu pour
lui autant les jeunes délinquants ils
sont peut-être très braves sont
peut-être très gentils peut-être qu'il y
en a que j'aimerais mais je suis en
perdant d'avance
avec l'ADN la police scientifique les
systèmes de police la nouvelle brigade
de recharge de Philippe Véronique et
ceci est cela ils sont perdants à
l'avance c'est à dire que moi si j'avais
un fils j'en ai un mais il sera jamais
délinquant il a 15 ans il a pas envie
mais si j'avais un fils de 20 ans qui me
disent papa je voudrais devenir de la
con j'aurais dû à faire la moitié de ta
vie en prison et la moitié de ta vie
aurait mis
j'avais 60 70 80 90 et jusqu'à la limite
de 95 ça a été beau pour les gens comme
nous
je crois qu'on peut un peu comparer
disons
ce marché de d'offre et de demande dans
le milieu illégal c'est fort comparable
à ce qui se passe dans la légalité dans
le monde légal c'est-à-dire qu'on fait
un screening
d'opportunités quels sont les risques
qu'on doit prendre pour pour avoir des
gains une fois que la Balance est
positive pour le truand il prend le
risque il va investir là-dedans et le
jour qui ressent que le risque est
beaucoup trop élevé ou que les gains ne
sont pas suffisants il va essayer de
changer de secteur ça c'est une ça c'est
une donnée ça c'est vrai
l'étude de marché a parlé
trop de risques et pas assez de profit
pour le banditisme à l'ancienne
[Musique]
bienvenue dans l'univers de la
cybernétique pour les nouveaux braqueurs
plus besoin de flingues de gilets par
balle d'explosifs
un écran un clavier une souris en un
seul clic plusieurs millions peuvent
être détournés numéro de compte bancaire
carte de crédit vente fictive tout
s'achète et tout se vend sur la toile
aussi facilement qu'un simple DVD
aujourd'hui dans le monde le business de
la cybercriminalité et supérieure à
celui de la drogue
rien qu'en France en 2008
269 millions d'euros ont été détournés
sur Internet et en dupliquant des cartes
bancaires pour ce business tout commence
avec un hacker un surdoué de
l'informatique
nous en avons rencontré un pierre qui
connaît toutes les astuces
et puis le fait falloir reconnaissance
des autres au début c'était ça quoi dire
ouais voilà j'ai piraté ça ça moi
j'étais content mais tu vois c'était
vraiment son
réel connaissance quoi j'allais sur sur
1000 Worms
les failles sur le site internet qu'on
pouvait trouver et puis Jean pirater le
plus possible
voyez certains sites qui référence les
les pirates selon nombre de
sites qu'ils ont qu'ils ont piraté et
puis à l'époque le grand jeu c'était
dans les premiers
envie de se surpasser de montrer ses
compétences d'être le premier à pirater
un site internet le hacking c'est
pouvoir par exemple modifier n'importe
quel site petite démonstration par
exemple si tu as un site internet
tu veux mettre si tu veux le modifier tu
te connectes via un client s'appelle
on va laisser en anonyme ici
par défaut et on se connecte
donc Pakistan télé donc là c'est toute
l'architecture du site
tu as toutes les pages qui sont là
donc ça c'est la page que j'ai pris du
site je vais la modifier pour voir si
on va faire une petite blague
un petit incident diplomatique
je prends l'adresse de l'image ici
donc le fichier édité on clique sur OK
pour le remettre sur le site et
ça marche il y a aucune protection
dessus
je retourne sur la page de tout de suite
là c'était newsletter on va rafraîchir
voilà
donc l'image que je viens de rajouter
dessus donc là tu as rajouté une image
dans un site internet
parce que donc le créateur du site a
laissé vraiment l'accès aussi
c'est assez libre c'est pour tout
ouverte
tout ce que tu veux
et ça c'est certain de pas te faire
opérer dans un truc pareil
c'est pour ça que j'ai pris un
site pakistanais et puis là je suis
connecté via un autre ordinateur donc ça
fait quand même deux chances de pas se
retrouver
modifier des sites pour faire des
blagues de potage ou plus dangereux
créer des faux sites internet ici un
faux de la State Bank reprenant les
logos du vrai site de la banque
américaine
les clients de la banque m'ont plus qu'à
tomber dans le panneau et communiquer
toutes leurs coordonnées bancaires aux
pirates du Net
[Musique]
autre technique
pénétrer dans les sites officiels
comme celui de banques coréale une
banque brésilienne
des administrateurs du site y ont laissé
trop de portes ouvertes pour tout bon
ibraker qui se respecte
les disques durs de la banque sont
grandes ouverts le butin login des
clients numéro de compte email adresse
historique facilement les transferts
d'argent peuvent s'opérer et le
ibracquage peut commencer
la référence des pirates cette et août
tenum alias analyseur il est le grand
hacker de ces 20 dernières années
dès l'âge de 18 ans il avait défrayé la
chronique en 1998 pour avoir infiltré
les ordinateurs du Pentagone et de la
knees 7 le parlement israélien embauché
à sa sortie de prison il travaillait
depuis 2003 pour la sécurité de l'État
d'Israël octobre 2008 il est à nouveau
arrêté pour avoir détourné plus de 1
million 200000 euros à une société de
crédit canadienne
on parle de 3 à 5 millions d'euros
ibraqués et tout cela sans arme et sans
violence
[Musique]
pour l'homme des belles américaines des
fifties les souris c'était autre chose
mais il n'aurait rien contre une petite
virée dans le cybermonde
[Rires]
heureux ce que sa pension de sa retraite
milliardaire que je puisse me la aller
là je fais bonjour honnêtement la
question sans violence sans rien vous
appuyez sur un bouton comment vous dites
d'Internet là là il y a des milliards et
là il y a rien vous avez besoin ou il y
a quelque chose vous pouvez de là amener
là vous pensez que je vais venir
si vous en avez une main
sur Internet plus de tontons flingueurs
en chapeau mou
et plus de policiers habitués aux flag
avec flingue mais des cyberlinés
en France c'est le clic le service du
commissaire divisionnaire Christian
agrum qui cyber trac les hackers en tout
genre
pour lui les hackers ne sont pas les
nouveaux Robins des bois et lorsqu'il
arrive au bureau il pose son arme
son ordinateur portable je dis il faut
arrêter il faut mettre un terme au cyber
romantisme le gamin de 16 ans boutonneux
dans sa chambre de bonne l'autre bout du
monde qui réussit à pénétrer dans les
plus grands réseaux
c'est pas ça la cybercriminalité c'est
pas ça la cybercriminalité c'est des
escrocs qui essayent de voler l'argent
de leur
de victimes très rapidement très
facilement et surtout sans avoir à rien
touché puisqu'on agit virtuellement ça
c'est la cybercriminalité à l'heure
actuelle c'est ça c'est ça et on a
affaire à des véritables réseaux
organisés on a affaire des préjudices
énormes
des réseaux sur la toile il en existe
comme IRC le logiciel de base qui sert à
concevoir les grandes chattes comme
Messenger ou Skype l'IRC et
téléchargeable gratuitement sur le net
des milliers de canaux spécialisés ils
sont hébergés et certains recèlent des
surprises c'est un système de chat de
dialogue avec des thèmes
assez intéressant comme par exemple ici
qui s'appelle carte bancaire Power et là
ça n'arrête pas c'est toute la journée
comme ça là je vends des cartes
bancaires américaines anglaises 1 dollar
le numéro
[Rires]
donc il donne le numéro le nom le prénom
des fois il adresse aussi du
propriétaire de la carte il donne le
petit code qui a derrière la date
d'expiration
et puis voilà puis le type de carte les
cartes bancaires avant de pas beaucoup
de monde qui ont été touché et là
maintenant
j'ai l'impression ouais ça a beaucoup
augmenté
tous ces réseaux à sur IRC je
connaissais pas du tout ça avant
on n'est pas du tout parlé quoi et
comment tu te expliques ça
ça augmente comme ça
la crise financière on a besoin d'argent
facile et puis bon on a l'impression
d'être en sécurité derrière son
ordinateur
à prendre les numéros de cartes comme ça
alors que alors que non
c'est vrai que l'argent facile c'est je
pense que c'est la principale motivation
on n'est pas là face à un phénomène
entre guillemets sympathique où on a
juste quelques petites personnes par-ci
par là qui se feraient escroqueraient ce
serait pas bien grave ce qui est
totalement faux parce que même si une
personne escroquée que de 100 euros ça
reste quand même 100 euros qui lui sont
volés au profit d'un délinquant
multiplié par des milliers de victimes
tout de suite on atteint des sommes
importantes d'une part d'autre part il y
a un risque véritable et la
compréhension de ces phénomènes
économiques nous amène à nous poser la
question sur quel est le risque est
véritable cybercriminalité comment
est-ce qu'on peut lutter efficacement et
quelle est la stratégie qu'on doit
adopter
difficile de mettre au point des
stratégies la technologie évolue vite et
les cybercriminels la maîtrise bien
au salon info sécurité ou se retrouve
tous les pros de l'antivirus on tente de
percer les secrets des pirates pour
trouver des parades
Marc Blanchard chercheur et cryptographe
depuis 20 ans suite en permanence
l'évolution des techniques utilisées
étant de les anticiper
petit voyage pour initier dans l'univers
des disques durs et du virtuel
aujourd'hui de multiples technologies
sont exploitées par les pirates alors on
va voir le cheval de Troie qui lui va
qui est un fichier en lui-même qui a une
mission c'est d'exploiter la machine
ensuite il a une bague d'or une bague
d'or c'est une porte dérobée une fois
que le cheval de Troie est sur la
machine il faut ouvrir des portes ces
portes là c'est les portes et ces PIP
ensuite on a un bottmet robot internet
c'est-à-dire que c'est un petit
processus qui va qui est compris en fait
dans le cheval de Troie qui a pour
mission en fait de récupérer l'adresse
Internet de l'utilisateur ou de
l'internaute et de l'envoyer aux pirates
[Musique]
le cheval de Troie c'est prendre le
contrôle d'un ordinateur le meilleur
moyen pour y arriver c'est d'y envoyer
des spams des messages indésirables qui
contiennent des logiciels espions c'est
la technique du fichier l'âme son âge
dans le jargon exemple vous recevez un
email banal vous disant chers clients de
la Société Générale le département
technique de la Société Générale procède
à une mise à jour de logiciels
programmée de façon à améliorer la
qualité des services bancaires nous vous
demandons avec bienveillance de cliquer
sur le lien ci-dessous et de confirmer
vos détails bancaires
où vous recevez un mail qui vous dit
savez vous qu'une vidéo de vous
circulent sur YouTube
vous cliquez dessus en pensant vous
diriger sur le site de YouTube
[Musique]
alors qu'en fait vous ouvrez une page
qui va installer le logiciel espion sur
votre ordinateur
vous êtes fichier une fois fiché
l'ordinateur devient une machine zombie
le pirate à distance est en temps réel a
accès à toutes les données et opérations
effectuées sur la machine page internet
visiter achat en ligne frappe clavier
les pirates chasse en priorité les
données personnelles une fois collectées
elles sont envoyées à un serveur central
puis revendu au plus offrant ces
machines zombies forment une sorte
d'armée c'est ce qu'on appelle un
malware qui peut toucher plusieurs
millions de machines en même temps
[Musique]
des premiers malware
il a été conçu par des Russes en 2007
on peut voir sur cet écran sa
propagation
d'ordinateurs de région en région de
pays à pays en moins de 24 heures il
aurait infecté près de 50 millions
d'ordinateurs dans le monde
les attaques vont très très vite c'est à
dire la publication des exploits
aujourd'hui
sont de l'ordre de toutes les 4 minutes
qui a un exploit alors qu'en 99 en 1999
un exploit était publié en moyenne tous
les 15 jours en 2004 toutes les 15
minutes aujourd'hui moins de 4 minutes
inutile de vous dire que pour un
administrateur de sécurité qui gère des
serveurs bancaires des serveurs
financiers même la bourse on va dire
c'est très difficile pour lui à moins de
s'équiper et d'avoir un budget colossal
de sécurité donc parce que humainement
ça suffit pas il faut des outils d'audit
qui coûte très très cher des sondes etc
et aujourd'hui le secteur bancaire
pris conscience de ces choses là mais
les autres
je dirais
secteurs sont beaucoup plus
laxistes à ce niveau là donc il y a
aujourd'hui une recrudescence
d'infection active par Internet
c'est-à-dire des serveurs Web que vous
allez visiter qui peuvent être des
serveurs publics serveurs de casino de
serveurs de jeux qui peuvent être
piratés à votre et c'est vous qui êtes
en fin de compte l'hébergeur de ce
malware pour le propager à tout le monde
fin 2007 500 000 programmes malveillants
2008 800 000 et pour 2009 sont attendus
au moins un million 300 000 malware il
est impossible aujourd'hui d'arrêter ce
type de réseau et à partir du moment où
il y a un minimum d'utilisateurs chaque
utilisateur est à la fois client et à la
fois serveur donc comme de plus en plus
d'utilisateurs rejoignent ces réseaux
parallèles même si on avait une loi ou
des principes technologiques pour
bloquer ce type de ça serait impossible
encore plus facile et rapide pour les
mafieux les téléphones portables dernier
cri connectés à Internet ou au réseau
Wi-Fi les malwares peuvent se propager
de portable à portable
lieu de prédilection les grands concerts
les manifestations sportives ou les
connecter son nombre les pirates
aujourd'hui ont tous les outils pour
transformer votre votre téléphone
portable en futur machine zombie
simplement ils attendent qu'une chose
c'est qu'il y a un standard du noyau qui
va faire fonctionner ces téléphones
portables pour se propager mais
technologiquement les pirates ont tout
ce qu'il faut pour utiliser votre
téléphone portable pour leur bien propre
ou pour faire du business exemple un
faux numéro que vous allez recevoir mais
qui est surtaxé et votre téléphone va se
mettre à composer toutes les 10 minutes
ce numéro surtaxé ça va certes vous
griller votre forfait mais le pirate va
en avoir beaucoup dans les poches au
niveau de l'argent
pour récupérer le cache détourné ou
faire des virements sur des comptes
offshore les réseaux ont besoin de
petites mains ce sont les mules comme
les passeurs du trafic de drogue pour
recruter une mule rien de plus simple
envoyer des offres d'emploi légende via
internet proposant de gagner 2000 euros
par mois pour 5 heures de travail par
semaine
le travail consiste à ouvrir un compte
et ce compte servira à transférer des
dizaines de milliers d'euros vers
l'Ukraine la réussite ou des comptes
offshore
le recrutement des mules c'est quelque
chose de relativement simple recevez un
mail dans lequel on vous dit est-ce que
vous avez du temps à perdre est-ce que
vous avez de l'argent à gagner est-ce
que vous disposez d'un petit peu de
ressources à savoir un ordinateur et
puis il y a peu de temps à consacrer et
un compte bancaire la plupart des gens
vous disent oui j'ai ça et bien si vous
acceptez de passer quelques heures avec
votre ordinateur et de déposer de
l'argent sur un compte bancaire puis de
le renvoyer vous allez gagner 10% des
sommes que vous recevez alors le baratin
c'est pour une entreprise qui a besoin
de liquidité etc on voyait toujours une
belle une belle romance qui permet de
mieux faire comprendre voilà donc les
bulles sont recrutés récupèrent l'argent
leur envoient et ça on l'a démontré à
travers les dossiers qu'on a pu traiter
où là en quelques mois
on arrive à une démultiplication de
petites sommes qui varient de centaines
milliers d'euros par compte bancaire on
arrive à des 600 000 euros très
rapidement de préjudice à l'encontre de
d'une
majorité des victimes qu'on a pu
déterminer en France
à aucun moment la mule ne sait pour qui
elle travaille réellement et elle n'a
aucun contact physique avec son donneur
d'ordre
lorsqu'une mule est arrêtée il est très
difficile pour les enquêteurs de
remonter le réseau
à la différence d'une complicité pour
braquage de banque la mule est mise en
examen pour blanchiment d'argent et
escroquerie elle ne risque pas les
assises mais la correctionnelle
un pro du blanchiment d'argent et du
cheval de Troie
tarikal Daour
[Applaudissements]
t Tariq et ses complices était
spécialisé dans la collecte de données
bancaires en piratant des achats en
ligne
non adresse numéro de carte et date
d'expiration était enregistrée
[Musique]
avec ces données piratées il
s'inscrivait sur des sites de poker en
ligne
tous les joueurs de la table virtuelle
étaient dans le cou il suffisait de
faire semblant de perdre et l'argent
était récupéré par un complice
l'argent volé un million 200000 livres
sterling a servi à acheter des tentes
des couteaux des bonbonnes de gaz et
tout type de matériel de camping pour
les envoyer en Irak
[Musique]
ils ont été arrêtés à Londres en juillet
2007 et inculpé pour financement de
groupes terroristes
en scène et vend son business sur
Internet s'appelle ciao il est turc et
il est le roi du ski Ming le piratage et
la duplication des cartes bancaires son
business vous piquez vos numéros de
cartes de paiement et les revendre plus
offrant une affaire qui roule jusqu'au
29 octobre dernier
[Musique]
Istanbul la police turque exhibe
fièrement des ordinateurs des cartes de
crédit du matériel de duplication des
téléphones portables elle vient
d'arrêter Ciao
non seulement il détournait des comptes
mais surtout il revendait l'équipe
nécessaire à la duplication de carte
dans les distributeurs
la police estime son chiffre d'affaires
à 1,8 millions de dollars lui cet arc de
1 milliard de dollars plus d'une
centaine d'arrestations se sont
déroulées le même jour au Canada et aux
USA pour faire tomber son réseau
cybervoler mais pas enfant de cœur Ciao
n'avait pas hésité à humilier et à
torturer un de ses complices à coeurs
nommé Pierre qui lui devait plus d'une
centaine de milliers d'euros
en France 30% des sommes détournées et
dues à la duplication de cartes le
dernier réseau a été démantelé en
décembre dernier
[Musique]
le réseau travailler de la manière
suivante une partie de l'équipe installe
des distributeurs automatiques de
billets falsifier d'accord installer des
faux des fausses des fausses façades
récupère les numéros de les numéros de
cartes falsifis des cartes donc
contrefait de nouvelles cartes puis
récupère l'argent d'accord par l'achat
de deux manières ou par l'achat direct
enfin par le retrait directement dans un
distributeur automatique de billets ou
bien par l'achat de matériel de grande
de grande valeur comme des
sacs à main de de
grandes factures des bouteilles d'alcool
du vin etc etc enfin des objets qui sont
facilement niables facilement
revendables voilà donc les matériels
sont revendus le profit et le profit et
le profit est fait pour l'instant on a
déterminé un préjudice de l'ordre de
200.000 euros en quelques mois
d'existence de l'équipe même pas six
mois
[Musique]
mais il en est qui résiste aux sirènes
du virtuel et aiment encore le travail à
l'ancienne pas les banques ou les
convoyeurs non ce qui les intéresse ce
sont les bijouteries ce sont les Pink
Panthers
en avril 2007 à Dubaï il n'hésite pas à
investir un centre commercial en voiture
et attaquer une bijouterie durée de
l'opération quelques minutes
crocus de diamant les fines panthères
sont surtout des braqueurs ultra
violents disposant d'une logistique
hollywoodienne et armée comme des
porte-avions
les Panthères roses sont devenus le
cauchemar des polices du monde entier
à l'image des grands voyous qui ont fait
trembler le bourgeois et tourner en
bourrique les flics de la fin des années
70 s'est fait l'un sont en train de se
forger une saga comme seul c'est en
cultivé la mythologie du grand
banditisme Genève Saint-Tropez
Courchevel ou encore Monaco ces
braqueurs sont à l'origine de plus de
110 vols à mains armés dans le monde
originaire des Balkans ayant connu la
guerre de Yougoslavie ils n'ont peur de
rien
en mars 2004 à Tokyo dans le quartier
chic de Ginza les voleurs circulaient à
vélo en portant des masques
anti-pollution avant de braquer en moins
de 40 secondes cette bijouterie et
emporter avec eux plus de 25 millions de
dollars de butin
4 décembre 2008 17h30 avenue Montaigne à
Paris
la bijouterie Harry Winston
les ping Panther aurait-elle encore
frappé 4 malfaiteurs dont 3 habillés en
femme se sont enfuis après s'être fait
remettre la quasi-totalité des bijoux
exposés un montant exceptionnel plus de
80 millions d'euros
un an auparavant cette joaillerie à la
clientèle internationale très aisée la
famille du shah d'Iran les Grimaldi
avaient déjà été la cible d'un audacieux
vol de bijoux estimé à plus de 10
millions d'euros
pour les deux braquages de l'avenue
Montaigne aucune piste et les bijoux
sont toujours dans la nature mais les
enquêteurs pensent au ping Panther
non la grosse bijouterie je sais
maintenant
85 million d'euros ce ne sont pas des
gendarmes centrale et je suis très
heureux que d'autres gens qui est-ce
alors
65 ans je vais m'y mettre
c'est une très belle affaire ils ont les
noms des employés et ça vous sont les
coffres secrets où il y a les gros
bijoux ce ne sont pas des gendarmes
centrales ce ne sont pas les mêmes que
d'habitude
maintenant attends je suis une très
belle affaire
moi j'ai fait une seule fois deux fois
dans ma vie une bijouterie mais jamais
en France l'Allemagne ils vont vendre
à 3 millions d'euros l'étiquette c'est
85 millions d'euros
c'est 20 millions d'euros de
marchandises en réalité parce qu'il
triple les gens chez quartier quartier
ils ont même pas de mouvement à eux
c'est des génies ça
mille euros l'assurance 20000 euros ça
vaut 2 millions d'euros de 20 millions
d'euros ça vaut 2 millions d'euros à la
fourrure si j'arrive à vendre avec des
fausses factures à Anvers chez les Juifs
de peluche comme j'ai fait une fois ils
vont en tirer 6 millions d'euros mais si
son cas avec
la personne qui a donné l'affaire ils
ont gagné 600.000 euros mais je suis
très content pour eux c'est des braves
gens ils ont gagné 600 000 euros chacun
c'est très beau à l'heure actuelle mais
ils ont pas pris plus il faut pas que
les gens
[Musique]
mais l'avenir n'est pas rose pour les
artistes de l'avenue Montaigne
les difficultés dans ces affaires-là
c'est pouvoir les bijoux il y aura
peut-être des petits y avoir des
surprises c'est là
vous avez besoin de telle valeur
voyez tous ceux qui ont eu des bijoux
dans les mains pas de l'époque c'est
rare que pour qu'ils arrivent pas à
receleur qui soit balancé par le de
l'époque
ce qui peut se passer là tous les revals
de bijoux de bijoux il y a eu donc
monsieur
d'autres mais quand vous avez des bijoux
que vous voulez négocier il est rare
que vous soyez pas d'être ici
se faire balancer par des revendeurs
c'est dans les cordes des anciens
mais imaginez le gangster du 21e siècle
c'est une autre paire de manches
[Musique]
je réponds à votre mission sur monsieur
je ne suis pas compétent sur ce qui se
passe sur internet je suis incapable de
rentrer sur Internet
j'ai 800 chaînes de télévision mais
c'est pas moi qui les drivent je suis
pas capable de les faire marcher quand
je suis en panne il faut que j'attende
quelqu'un pour me le dépanner
en fonction de la technologie serrure en
fonction de la technologie machin les
braquages un jour ce sera fini toute
façon moi je donne mon avis il y a plus
de délinquance
les serrures sont plus en plus dures à
faire les fourgons sont plus en plus
alors maintenant il y a une nouvelle
délinquance chez les traders
voilà mais il faut y avoir accès c'est
pas le mec d'Aubervilliers des cités qui
va être Rader moi je viens de perdre
beaucoup d'argent mais je peux pas en
parler
l'histoire de main d'Off aux États-Unis
tout le monde la connaît je peux citer
sans trader entre la Belgique surtout le
Luxembourg et surtout la Suisse et un
petit peu ailleurs qui font exactement
pareil que Mendo
alors les gens un client il donne 5% par
mois ils ont un autre client ils ont 25%
par mois le mec ramène un client est
dans 5% par mois alors ça y est je suis
bénis des dieux il me donne 3% ici à la
banque par an et j'ai 5% par mois puis
bien bonjour le trader disparaît
ça m'est arrivé il y a pas longtemps
voilà est-ce que tu considères les
trésors comme un peu les nouveaux
braqueurs
vraiment les traders actuels de je suis
chez du Liechtenstein et de Luxembourg
ce sont des braqueurs géniaux je peux
pas leur en vouloir mais c'est
délinquants moi ils m'ont volé mais j'ai
volé toute ma vie j'accepte d'être venu
mais c'est les génies
chez les docteurs hold-up il y a comme
un brin de jalousie envers les rois du
disque dur
meilleur est-il des volontaires pour
monter au braquage virtuel
on voit les anciens braqueurs se
tournaient vers des formes de
criminalité qui sont moins physiquement
violentes quand on a de l'arthrite c'est
plus dur de sauter les de sauter les
compteurs de banque ça c'est évident
donc on va aller voir par exemple dans
la contrefaçon de carte bancaire ça oui
venant proximétisme etc
on voit pas encore une génération
d'anciens de ce genre se tournait vers
la cybercriminalité tel que tel que tout
le monde l'a conçoit lié à la
criminalité informatique tout simplement
parce qu'il y a un effort générationnel
à faire on va voir arriver ça dans les
années prochaines bien sûr parce qu'on
aura parce que les jeunes de maintenant
sont formés aux différentes aux
différents outils de communication et
vont donc grandir avec ces outils de
communication et donc là on aura une
partie de la délinquance qui a grandi
qui aura utilisé les moyens des
nouvelles technologies pour commettre
leur méfaits et qui va rapidement se
tourner vers ces moyens qui sont à la
fois entre guillemets
et incolore puisque considéré comme
virtuel qui sont moins réprimés mais
d'un rapport beaucoup plus juteux que le
moindre vol à armé que mis à l'heure
actuelle ça va l'homme armée c'est les
assises une escroquerie sur Internet
c'est la correction
des armes ou des logiciels un conflit de
génération
comme un parfum de révolution dans le
petit monde des criminels
[Musique]